ja ich finde aber ist reichlich absurd
die Debatten die da aus der Union gerade
kommen also ernsthaft zu erzählen man
habe einen Auftrag zu regieren nachdem
man 8% Punkte verloren hat oder noch
mehr nachdem man historische
unbeliebtheitswerte hat nachdem man
wirklich alles falsch gemacht hat was
man in einem Wahlkampf falsch machen
kann die Dreistigkeit zu haben jetzt
davon zu sprechen man habe ja ein
Regierungsauftrag und könnte irgendwie
so weitermachen wie vor ist ja gar
nichts passiert warum denn dann machen
wir halt Jamaika dann ist die Angela
Merkel weg aber ich ziehe dann
Kanzleramt ein und wird alles ganz
gemütlich das finde ich absurd und ich
kann das immer auch noch nicht so
richtig glauben dass da niemand in der
Union mal aufsteht und sagt moment mal
Hallo Aufwachen hallo Armin Aufwachen
wir haben 8% Punkte verloren und dass
man sich jetzt dahin stellt und sagt ja
wir wollen jetzt da in die Regierung ich
kann es mir schon so richtig vorstellen
wie Armin Laschet jetzt im Konrad
adenauer-haus sitzt und die ganze Zeit
auf seinem Handy hin und her Tippen mit
Christian Lindner und sagt na ja mit uns
ist schon viel schöner besser und dann
passiert auch nichts schlimmes also der
wird alles dahin werfen damit er diese
koa kommt ich finde ja wir brauchen eine
Debatte auch mal darüber was eigentlich
bei der Union passiert ist und offenbar
in der Union selbst will man die nicht
führen jetzt haben wir ganz vergessen
unseren vierten Gast hier zu begrüßen
deswegen guten Abend an dein Handy was
sagt das denn gerade Werner im
Hintergrund wirklich jetzt schon die
Messer gewechselt vielleicht die ersten
ein bisschen kaputt ja
hat einige mpks durchgemacht also was
ich höre ist das in der SPD ziemliche
Ungläubigkeit darüber herrscht wiederum
was die Grünen angeht dort ist man etwas
verstört über die Aussagen von Robert
Habeck man hätte sich gewünscht dass der
sich viel klarer äußert was man außerdem
hört aus der SPD dass man davon ausgeht
dass die Grünen sich jetzt zerfleischen
könnten in dieser Nacht dass da die
großen Messer fliegen denn es soll eine
Art dir gegeben haben zwischen Robert
Habeck und Anna-Lena baerbock das wenn
das Ergebnis unter 15% fehlt das dann
Robert Habeck die Fäden übernimmt was
man aus der FDP hört in diesen Minuten
in diesen Stunden ist das Christian
Lindner und Wolfgang Kubicki erstmal ein
Wein trinken wollen und darüber sprechen
wollt das war die zeitparty aber der da
wird Wolfgang nicht lange bleiben dann
wird man sich zusammensetzen und dann
versucht man im engsten Kreis dort etwas
festzulegen und tatsächlich wollen FDP
und Grüne das erstmal unter sich
ausmachen und das ist ja spannend
offenbar versuchen die gerade eine
Koalition der Kanzlerschaft zu formen
warum der Kanzlerschaft weil sie
zusammen so mächtig sind dass sie den
Kanzler bestimmen können wenn du das
hörst wenn du jetzt hörst zu Hause
sitzen die Wählerinnen und Wähler haben
brav wir Kreuzchen gemacht in Berlin
teilweise zu wirklich widrigen Umständen
wie wir gerade gehört haben und den
ganzen Tag über und dann sitzt man da
jetzt bald ist Mitternacht und weiß
irgendwie weiß man überhaupt gar nicht
wie das weitergeht in diesem Land man
hat überhaupt keine Ahnung irgendwo
werden Messer gewetzt und andere
Schachen Positionen hin und her was geht
schwer durch den Kopf ja der deutschen
Bürger ist der Nacht 2017 live geprüft
im koalitions finden also verschlimmer
als 2017 wo dann die die
Jamaika-Koalition dann geplatzt ist
damals hat Chris Linda ja gesagt lieber
nicht regieren als falsch zu regieren
deswegen ist natürlich jetzt die
koalitionsfindung extrem spannend Klaus
Strunz hat ja heute mehrfach über die
groko gesprochen das ist ja auch noch
eine Möglichkeit wäre das glaube ich
jetzt nicht aber ich habe trotzdem gerne
klar weiß ich aber noch mal ganz kurz
sagen möchte wo ich heute ganz lange
darüber nachgedacht habe als ich immer
wieder diese Wahlergebnisse gesehen habe
moment mal eine Sache ist doch jetzt
komplett klar wenn der Parteien hohes
Ergebnis haben will stellen den Kanzler
dann gibt es trients der Kanzlerkandidat
kriegt extrem viel Aufmerksamkeit ich
finde das Wahlergebnis heute ich weiß
die Union wurde abgestraft aber ich habe
mich schon heute abend öfter gefragt wie
wäre es denn gewesen wenn Christian
Lindner als Vierter Kanzlerkandidat da
gewesen wäre
trotzdem man kann trotzdem mal darüber
schauen
verflossenen Tränen ich finde das ist
man trotzdem das ist schön dass ihr
beiden das sagen würde dann freuen
ich habe heute bei Phoenix gesehen
Statistik die fand ich höchst spannend
und zwar hat Armin Laschet doppelt so
viel Schmähungen im Social Netz bekommt
die Vermehrungen wie Scholz und bärbock
gemeinsam und da muss man schon sagen es
war ja auch ein großer medienwahlkampf
ich bin jetzt gespannt was die Zeit
bringt ich finde es gar nicht so absurd
das Laschet auch noch probiert eine
Koalition zu finden lädt sie aber leid
geprüft sind wir nach 2017 ich hoffe es
geht schnell schnell gehen
[Musik]